we've done a series of hardware videos
with dots bagley about various different
parts of CPUs and things like this and
one of the things he'd mentioned during
one of the videos is something that I
believe you want to tell us a bit more
about the the wheeler jump yes the
wheeler jump dari wheeler
very very talented computer scientist as
excellent lateral thinking I didn't know
him very well I knew him very slightly
maybe met him four or five times but you
just had to be impressed that he as a
computer pioneer had to grapple with the
fact that very early computers did not
have enough registers in their CPUs
registers just like tiny bits of memory
are habits of memory but within the
central processor unit they could be
built of much faster technology than
main memory so typically you know like
with the ARM chip at user level you'd
end up with 16 general-purpose registers
one or two of those might be set aside
to use for all sorts of useful things
and one of the useful things was the
idea of you running through your program
you want to jump into a subroutine to
calculate a sign or to print out hello
world or something like that you don't
want it to be running linearly on your
program you want to jump into it and
jump back out of it again so you could
use it several times in your program
from several different places you could
jump in and jump back out now David
wheel is credited with this idea of
inventing the subroutine and say well
yeah when people want to calculate sign
of something they don't want to have to
replicate in their program the coding
for sign in six different places might
make it go faster and of course some of
you will know that if you write macros
you can force it to do that sacrifice a
lot more code for faster speed but no to
keep it clean you basically say I want
this piece of code to be separate but
jumpable into and jump back out a ball
from back to where you came from so
before you jump in at the month of the
jump you've got to say where am i coming
from
whose responsibility is it to remember
that any modern CPUs you would have a
link register of some sort that
remembers didn't have that in the very
early days but boy did it dawn on them
that you needed it so if you didn't have
a link register how on earth were you
going to get into and out of your
subroutine so let's say you're coming
from 70 shall we say location 70
something like that right now on this
particular occasion therefore when you
get back out of that subroutine you
don't want to go back to 70 itself
because you'd end up in an endless loop
of jumping back into yourself you want
to go to the instruction just beyond 70
but you want to get back out you want to
remember 70 AD while depending on the
architecture you add 1 to 4 depending
when it's a byte machine a word machine
whatever but you add a small number on
to that address and say that's where I
want to get back to the instruction
after where I jumped from and and the
problem is that you've got nowhere to
save well on modern machines 70 would be
saved in a link register
maybe register number 14 or something
you say jump to subroutine the moment
you say it you to automatically
remembers where you're jumping from and
puts it in the link register so when you
want to come back out you say Here I am
on this architecture where's my link
register number 14 let's look at its
content oh it says 70 and I'm on a
32-bit machine with 4 bytes to the word
so that's I want to jump for beyond 70
or if it's you know like EDSAC it might
be one or two beyond but you want to
just jump back to where you came from
slightly adjusted with a little amount
added and it is that link register that
saves you from going insane now back in
the early days of David wheeler and this
edsac machine he had to do this for Oh
golly I wish I had an extra register but
I haven't
what register how I got this in use all
the time that might if I'm very careful
serve me all right and the answer is the
arithmetic accumulator
every time you loaded a number into the
accumulator or did some arithmetic the
answer stays in the accumulator okay so
here's the deal we're going to use the
arithmetic accumulator as the means of
remembering where we came from so here
you are at location 70 in the early
EDSAC machine what do you have to do so
you have to add 70 to 0 awesome
yes it's basically yes you're jumping
from 70 ok 70s got to be in the
accumulator at the moment of jump and
then you do an unconditional branch
instruction to get to the start of the
subroutine fine
but you wake up in that subroutine your
first job is to preserve your link to
get back you must not do any arithmetic
because you feel like it duty calls
you must save off your return link
somewhere safe right because if you
don't you won't be able to get back but
you have no spare so we've got nowhere
to say no spare registers to save it
yeah you might think so but how about
this suppose at the bottom of your
subroutine there is a branch instruction
a dummy one which is basically going to
say branch or jump back to where I came
from but where I came from
must be a literal correct address and in
the accumulator is 17 so what you that
have to do is knowing the length of your
subroutine and its addresses and knowing
where the return instruction is planted
as a dummy you've basically got to turn
70 into 72 74 whatever it is to make it
go back to the next instruction after
where you came from and you must
literally plant that instruction and
shock horror over write your own program
code at the bottom of this subroutine so
that the dummy jump which has probably
got zeros left in it now becomes jump
back to location so
- shall we say but you are actually
altering memory now can you imagine if
that goes wrong how to debug a program
that's trampling all over itself and
jumping back to the wrong address you
know code gets altered all the time
right can you give us some sense of how
sacrosanct these lines of code are when
it's running well code may seem to alter
itself all the time but it's usually
altering itself by manipulating
registers in the CPU not physically
overwriting memory in your main memory
store so it's okay to obviously change
the value for variables and and all of
that but actually changing those lines
of code should be changing variables is
fine that's data you're allowed to
change data what you're not allowed to
do is to treat a program instruction bit
pattern as if it was just a piece of
data and to patch something on top of it
to read now you can do this on z8 since
I've tried doing it if you go very
simple chips there's no protection
mechanisms they'll let you do anything
you want and you just hang yourself fine
more advanced chips now and particularly
operating systems make use of this give
you an ability to mark which pieces of
memory are read-only and are not to be
overwritten and that way you can stay
fairly sane
although you've left behind a polluted
piece of code saying jump back to 72 the
next time you come into this routine
maybe having jumped from 256 shall we
say you've now got to remember to fire
six in the accumulator the moment you
get in there you were just it ever so
slightly to come back to two five eight
or whatever it is and you plant that
instruction to overwrite the jump back
to 72 which is still there literally
inside your code so every single call
you're making to that subroutine the
link back has to overwrite whatever
usage you had before and plant it in
exactly the right place to get back you
can see now why the moment own sack too
came all of a sudden this had linked
registers all of this early experience
just showed the Pioneers
what the next generation of machinery
had to have and that's how the
importance of link register z' became
obvious it will have occured to you of
course Shawn I think I've got this right
that doing it the day David wheel away
with a wheel of jump right you
successively at the end of your routine
of writing back and patching it with
your address you need to get back to
that's fine and it'll work but what does
that not enable you to do begins women
are further a recursion yeah one of the
reasons for wanting a more general
mechanism for doing it is you can't do
recursion with the wheeler method
because you've only got one place in
memory at the end of the subroutine
where you patch back a new return
address what you need with recursion is
to have several return addresses all
waiting to be used
queued up normal queued up stacked up on
a stack so that's the other thing
recursion is obviously a very particular
special case but does this wheeler jump
not even allow you to do branches in
branches oh you can do that yes yes you
can do that but but actually having you
know a thing call itself since you wrote
textually only got one copy of the
routine just one you're not able to
replicate the text in any way there's no
ability to do that you can only damage
that one return address just the one
that means that no next realization from
being a pioneer is my golly we've gotta
be able to do recursion my golly we need
of all general-purpose registers and and
all this kind of stuff and oh also
wouldn't it be nice to put a marker on
memory saying don't let anybody override
this and actually have it Hardware
imposed not just by people's good nature
and this depends on the value being
fetch from there and I'm just going to
show this as an arrow here but the next
instruction load R 2 comma C well I
doesn't depend on anything